[Music]
in the internet never forgets news
submitted by chillin at the Holiday Inn
a popular female gamer through her cat
during a twitch stream and sparked a
messy drama okay cats know since they
always land the right way now somebody
get an answer
Alexa that's where you need her because
they always land on their feet let Alexa
did you ever hear that joke that was
like if toast always lands butter side
up and cats always land on the feet what
happens if you stop toast to the back of
the cat and drop it holy that was like
my aim Oh a message in like 2002 that's
not even a joke to me that's like an
actual scientific yeah I think that
confirms that you played oboe yeah
that's a real bandeau thing weren't you
in marching band to rhom line I was in
the pit xylophone I know but that's
different equally geeky but in the geek
hierarchy I guess the drums are less
geeky but for the rest of the cool guys
like us there's no play sport
yeah that was drama club I was wrong bro
yeah oh [ __ ] did you play sports I mean
technically I played sports not PE
though PETA's no no no I know I played
basketball I wrestle okay you're back in
your Becca I played basketball I play
soccer I wasn't good yeah it doesn't
count you're back you're back
I should be I'm torn both ways yells
sorry what are we talking about March
playing oboe you have to roll your feet
yeah yeah yeah I remember those I mean
they made a movie about your instrument
they didn't make one up although there's
an amazon show about it Nick Cannon
sucks a drum window there's a Hulu Plus
show about an oboist no that's what it
sounds like it just sounds like okay so
we're talking about this gamer who threw
the cat so her name is Natalia aka
illinit II and she is a popular gamer
with more than eight hundred and
ninety-two thousand followers on Twitter
142,000 followers on YouTube so she's
more known as a livestreamer like a
twitch streamer and so she has been in
controversy before I'll talk about that
later right now I will show you the clip
that went viral the Turner cap I want to
see how she do course she's hot it's so
throwing the cat clip first and then the
second clip is her giving her cat
something that you will see I would
focus on how the cat Lance oh it [ __ ]
by the kiss Oh Russian Columbian oh I
like how Bruno Mars is playing him so
cool okay so Peter
oh no oh says attention twitch support
take a stand for cats and please remove
an illinit Ephraim twitch immediately
she is using the platform to post animal
abuse which sends a dangerous message to
anyone watching her videos cats are not
props to abuse for more views abusing
cats ain't gonna get you more views
didn't do it for views Merle this just
seems like let's take the pretty girl
down kind of move how so
whose thing kitty like that what if she
ain't what she should lose her job for
it and everything Jesus what if she
aimed for the bed though and maybe
there's a big beanbag chair buying
around they should take her kid away be
good you feel good about that
get a plan give her a flank you know
where they give it to their home it's
tough yeah I picture the cat landing
though maybe that's why you [ __ ] but
anyway in a way yeah it's just chillin
yeah but it said [ __ ] you [ __ ] cuz I
didn't like it no no that
you can't jumped on her and she went oh
[ __ ] like that got angry uh it looked to
me like she was doing it like it's part
of her shtick like she's trying to gain
attention Oh cat watch how cool on the
throw it over my head I felt like less
of a reaction and more of like a like
that's her SH but what if what if we're
miss judging her culturally like for
example oh like a Colombian cat lover if
we go to India right and then you see
like a bunch of dudes holding hands
they're like okay but did I know what
are just gangbangers these the
difference between those examples is
what I'm so the gangbangers they're all
dudes hold hands right so I'm like you
can't judge it with the American Way
yeah but know what if that's a Colombian
affection technique I think that hold
due to due to holding hands is gay in
all countries and not in India they call
me the gangsters do that
no really their best friend they should
be upside down they should probably go
on the internet and then learn bug maybe
not doing that so much yeah they like to
hold pinkies to go wrong with the pinkie
they're not hurting anybody and if
anything they're expressing their
tightness by the pinkie hold with
whereas this cat he's like what did I do
that's [ __ ] up well I guess to Patino
devil's advocate maybe the cat enjoys
like maybe that's their like
relationship it's like acrobatic maybe
they just are so graceful when they're
flying for the air so I heard if she did
that to a turtle
I'd be outraged me too you don't throw
turtles over your head like that or a
dog cuz the dog will hurt itself yeah
are just so graceful I don't know how I
feel anymore I feel like I just talked
myself out of it I do that all the time
everyone here is correct
no that's the same conversation that's
happening online where people are like
well it's not that bad and plus it kind
of looked like she like kind of just
dropped it not through the hat and like
yes she didn't go and it like sports
sports but some people are like she went
bad but then other people are like no
she just swooped in drops and whatever
the point is that yes it's a little
controversial like we don't really know
if it's right or wrong because people
are taking two different sides the part
that everyone is like nah that's [ __ ]
up is the vodka because you could
clearly
see how yeah the cat hated that and it's
just like like animals can't process
alcohol and like straight up vodka is
like might as well give him gasoline
she gave him vodka yeah I thought you
gave a little kiss no vodka Trish oh
yeah she put vodka in her mouth and then
the cat drank it out of her mouth
whoa and that's how the cat was like
twitching I see now watch it the vodka
part again no no I get it no I think
that was what was like really mean
versus the tossing thing that tossing
was like I Adam you can interpret it in
a different way probably a lot of people
I know probably like my wife and a lot
of people would think that that just
shows a pattern of behavior that's
actually being shitty to the cat and
other situations she just did it twice
on camera because I want to add miss
something I threw a cat yeah but then
how old are you maybe six that makes
that seven but then I was well the cat
kept coming back right and then so I
would like I don't wanna hear maybe but
I named him Jerry
like Tom and Jerry he was a straight
arrow but I kept playing with Jerry and
I and I would throw him like this and
then he would do the flip and then you
would come back again and then I just
kept going like that and I was like you
always land really good but what if I do
this and I went BAM and then he I threw
him down like that and then his back hit
the floor and I'm like oh that's too
short
hi Peter thanks for watching and we hope
that you subscribe we were sick though
he was sick no no that's Winnie what I
hope happens can I just say I genuinely
would be really fun if you had to make
an apology video about you the six years
old and throwing a cat I really do think
that the Internet's ready for that i
legit didn't know I was just kind of
like testing Howell we believe you cuz
you're sick you know bothers me most
about that story what is that I can't
stop thinking about wasn't Jerry the
mouse tom was the cat all this irony I
don't know but I needle discover maybe
my dumb ass always thought Jerry was the
cat cuz whatever I named him Jerry but
yeah and then I think when I dropped him
he was only like a foot away from the
ground you were probably a foot away
from the ground
like got on your room job use it no no I
wouldn't like I would like this and I
went like that oh [ __ ]
and then I mean I remember this vividly
the bit the cat did not land via Slee it
was on his back and then he still came
back though after and I was like ok I'm
sorry
ok maybe I could fix this were you in
India where guys old hands his gangster
or it might be ok yeah I was in my
backyard but I didn't slap him on
concrete we had like mulch
we had a big mulch thing what were you
like like your your kidnapper oh yeah he
could have been free of you and he's
kept coming back but I didn't do it
again like after that you know I went
back to the normal tossing mmm she
didn't stop you have actor like Chris it
kept coming back to me I thought we were
playing the game the cat yeah I like
pushing my cat over when he's on the bed
I like just pushing him over and making
him slump over that's my favorite
because he jumped on me while I was
sleeping and it was it was a reaction I
was like Lena my bet it was my it was my
roommates cat in college her name was
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz she was guess what [ __ ]
a [ __ ] and I was sleeping and she
jumped on me and my closet was like
right here and I just went she was like
oh my RA why she attacked me I didn't
know what it was I was just react
you were defending yourself in that
little creature let's cut that bird
scared - yeah dude they're domesticated
Tigers my cat jump full on I'm in a deep
sleep it's like 4:00 a.m. and my cat all
of a sudden just jumps on my neck like
out of nowhere from the ground on my
[ __ ] neck it's not nowhere yeah cuz
he's jumping on the bed - good call sir
- Nikki but he [ __ ] climbs on me to
get there isn't a loopy pause yeah right
with his puppy ass pause we clean them I
feel like the only animals that are
allowed to be thrown are cats and birds
that's all let me bring it back to you
get up oh yeah there you go
play that back so this girl she lives in
Canada which that controversy I
mentioned earlier
is that last year she mentioned on a
live stream that she came or she went to
Canada kind of that after marrying a
Canadian so she was in Columbia in
medical school or she's like I want to
get out of here so she married a
Canadian guy and then she divorced him
right after and she just laughed about
it
so then 90-day fiance so then people
just got very upset for citizenship so
pewdiepie got involved somehow like he
was looking at this compilation thing
not what that same story but a different
story a different controversy where he
was like he called her and other girls
stupid twitch thoughts and then she
started saying that she's gonna propose
and she's gonna issue a copyright strike
against his channel or a copy strike and
then that ended up like he ends up
getting a strike and that's a whole
other story but the whole point here is
that she's no stranger to controversy it
seems like there's a lot of strikes
against her character exactly like all
the crosses we're not just Pat's but
like doing this and doing that and then
so she's just controversial oh I would
take her down who just changed her own
thing because I didn't even know who she
was in the beginning and I was just like
you know what women have it hard because
not only do guys talk [ __ ] but other
jealous women talk [ __ ] and they just
can't get a break
and that's why I know as poor chick
she starts a twitch yeah he takes her
tits out and she immediately gets a huge
following and I think that that's
terrible whole controversy where people
are saying that twitch is actually going
very lenient on her because they're
saying that they've banned
other male twitch streamers for less
being like less controversy and so
people are that's the other side of this
controversy or is that they're like the
[ __ ] she needs to be banned like but
she's good to look at so it's difficult
for them to go I'm gonna ban you you
know it's like ninja everyone watches it
because it's such a hottie yeah
the saskatoon Society for the Prevention
of Cruelty to Animals announced that a
formal cruelty complaint regarding this
manner matter has been filed and so they
will be investigating this whole thing
they will be doing like wellness checks
she sounds like a demon to me so make
sure that she's not abusing her cats she
even tweeted out hey everyone
understand the concern and I am sorry
for my lapses in judgment I shouldn't
have gotten frustrated with Milo but I
dropped him on the floor behind my chair
I'm not that strong the vodka thing was
well over a year ago yeah I use whiskey
now guys lots of stupid thing to do
I do I do a white wine spritzer yeah I
also understand the desire to report me
to pet authorities and encourage anyone
and I encourage anyone to do so if they
feel are being mistreated by anyone
anywhere my animals are well loved and I
live in a warm and caring home and I
will comply with any authority that
seeks to validate this I think a lot of
people are doing this because they
believe they are doing the right thing
so no salt I don't pretend to be perfect
and I will always try to do better and
improve myself a limiting machinery for
citizenship but I mean if she really
married for citizenship wouldn't the law
have like figured that out that's pretty
hard to do there's a lot of like what if
you like imagine this is tough like I
just want to hear no have you done that
like a lot if that got films that would
suck oh yeah I would have gone to jail
you stupid shouldn't lecture her life be
over yep exactly because I'm jealous I'm
jealous I don't want her to do any I
don't want her to have any attention yes
yes what makes a lot of money on that
Twitter and I don't like that I don't
like it either
she needs to be better at hiding all of
the bad things that dough does and she
needs to pretend to be a good person at
Leena's outwardly facing yes
[Music]